she wore
a cream-colored shirt whose collar
was decorated with a thin ribbon of satin
or dark leather
I couldn't recognize
the material with certainty she was perfect
I thought or advertisement for the brand
gérard darel I don't know  remember very well
that's exactly that
simple modern sophistication
the deft mix of classic
bourgeois tofs and daring details
i know who you are and i'm
happy to meet you ms she
said after a while i probably should
have  ask her what her name
was who she was invited to see what
she did for a living but i
felt intimidated by this woman her
quiet assurance
she was that kind of woman who
fascinates me exactly
she was flawless straight hair
the  nails perfectly limay and covered
with a vermilion red which seemed to re him
in the dark
I have always admired women who
wear nail polish
painted nails represent p  or me a certain
idea of feminine sophistication which I end
d up admitting that under this aspec
in any case it should not be inacc
ssible my hands are too wide too b
g too powerful in a certa
n way and w
en I try to varnish my  nail
it seems wider still as if
this vain attempt at disguising
by emphasizing the masculine character in
itself anyway the operation
always seemed laborious to me the gesture in
itself requires meticulousness a patience
that I do not have well  how long does it take to
be a woman like that I was wondering while
observing the
as I had observed dozens of
women before her in the metro in the
waiting line from cinemas to
restaurant tables wearing makeup
ironing without a crease
how many  time to achieve this
state of perfection each morning and
how long in the evening for
touch-ups before going out
what kind of life does it take to
have the leisure to tame your hair
in brush shing to change jewelry
every day to match and vary her
outfits to leave nothing to chance
today I know that it is not
only a matter of availability
is rather of gender what kind of
woman chose it  to be if we
have the choice